which policies which philosophy makes
more sense libertarian or socialism
let me let me ask you one more hang on
let me ask a question let me ask a
question a different way what is the
more marketable yep philosophy to sell
libertarian or social 100 it's a great
point generally speaking the left does
very well with socialism because it
sounds great the rhetoric is amazing
rich people suck listening you know
packs the reason we're all going to be
happy we're all going to it's all going
to be finished explain the success of
aoc in your districts over there it
sounds amazing so they're right when it
comes to rhetoric the socialists are
very good at that they're good at saying
everyone's going to be fair everyone's
going to be safe everything all the
riches
it is and it feels good i think it does
go well which is why you don't hear me
talk about libertarianism i talk about
solutions only just solutions i want the
person in front of me to go oh if
they're republican you're republican if
they're democrat you're a democrat
that's what i want them to do i don't i
don't push philosophy you didn't hear me
push philosophy here all i talk about is
here's my solution i'm a candidate a
candidate has to have they ask you a
question
are you republican or democrat what do
you say i would say independent
libertarian independent libertarian is
your answer that's what i say how much
door knocking are you doing me
personally not that much i'm not shaking
hands i'm i'm not knocking on doors i'm
out in events literally how many events
are you doing how many events are you
doing um just
i'm not when i'll i'll go back i'll do
three tomorrow
two on sunday
i'm two on saturday three on sunday
so far none scheduled for monday but i
do probably 15 a week 15 events a week
give or take and the average audience is
what how many how many people are doing
low end i'll get three or four high and
i'll get a couple hundred okay got it so
you're on that area you're hustling
you're going you're going after the
house you're doing your product okay
i've got to get 45 000 signatures that
are legal which means i have to get 60
pounds i understand so so you can make
sure that works so you transitioned
where i was going you brought it more to
present today which as a great marketer
that means you're you're good at doing
that as well that's good what i will say
is the following but you also about an
hour and a half ago you said in order
for me to do this i got to get
registered and i need this much money to
be able to do this this that okay great
if i
am
hustling today
i would be so proactive to get in front
of five influencers
to get them to put up money and say okay
great guess what here's 10 million bucks
yeah here's 20 million bucks
there's two things and i'm talking an
influencer and i understand what you're
saying because it's federal this is more
state so you have to go more but if if
that guy does it
on the national level the local people
are now saying if so so now your
presentation becomes did you guys see
rubble mustard what here's my mustard no
way yeah
seriously yeah here's one [ __ ] i'm in
okay what do we need here's what we need
to do we need to get a more new year
what you're saying i'm literally doing
andrew yang endorsed me right so i am
getting bigger fixtures to do it but the
problem is most people aren't backing me
yet you know why they don't think i can
get in the ballot
so why in the world would you back me
throw money and i've already raised six
figures like i've already raised six
figures already so i'm already raising
money so i do raise money but why would
you if i go hey patrick give me uh forty
thousand dollars and you go why you're
not gonna be in the ballot you're right
i gotta get in the ballot first when i
get in the ballot and you go oh you're
gonna be on the ballot okay larry let me
let me write you a check but there's
also amount of money i can give i've got
to create a pack then if i want to get
more than forty thousand dollars so
there's limitations how much money i can
even take my average donation in in 2018
was 85
i raised half a million dollars and my
average donation was 85 dollars
so what's that number 85 times half a
million how many people i don't know how
much that is it's a thousand would be
eighty five thousand dollars so ten
thousand would be eight fifty so you
have like seven thousand seven thousand
people but i had a couple big heavy
hitters had a couple of those who gave
me like thirty twenty it doesn't matter
but you got six thousand so some of them
give you five bucks which is great so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]